للفيديو الذي كنا اذناه قبل قليل من
الاعلام الاسرائيلي لفرح الجنود
الاسرائيليين
بسحب جنود اللواء جولاني من غزه نتابع
ونستمع ايضا الى ما يقولون عبر
الترجمه نحن نريد ان نعود الى الاحتفالات
احتفالات جولاني
[موسيقى]
هنا الاف هنا مستره ورا
وايضا هناك من يغني بشكل مثير المحاربون
لولاني والذين حاربوا في
غزه وايضا هنا يعودون الى هنا من جانب اخر
للانتعاش
وايضا هناك المشاعر المختلفه في هذا
المساء وهذا امر يرفع
المعنويات وبالهدف نقول لهم شكرا شكرا
وقول لهم شكرا جزيلا وايضا يستحقون ان
ينتعش نريد ان نعود الى هذه الاحتفالات
هناك الاحتفالات مازالت مستمره هنا وراءنا
وبن اري مازال يغني وفي امر مثير للمشاعر
المحاربون
لولاني من ناحيه اخرى كانوا في غزه وهنا
اليوم هنا يعودون الى هنا اليوم من اجل
الانتعاش ومن اجل ان نشاهد هنا المشاعر
المختلفه في هذا المساء الذي يرفع
المعنويات وخاصه نقول لهم شكرا ونحن نقول
لهم شكرا بالذات على كل ما نقام به هناك
وهم الان يعودون للانتعاش
وبعد ان كانوا في
غزه